I got a little box of in listening oh I
was wondering tiger it's not refillable
but why should be in so I don't salon
with her drink I just did a new bottle
tiny box had nothing left over recording
oh my god you guys it's got a real slice
of life you wonder what it's like
hanging out with neighbor night off
camera it's exactly that hi guys my name
is resolving didn't know now you know
your life is different now friend I'm
here with mamrie Hart
here Cheers pretty why do you do that
comment we had a video on memories
channel a cute and rode day where we
answer some of your most burning
questions and Drain froze a yes
brilliant kanji I got into a k-hole of
law really recall videos today and I
found out that he released a new song
few days ago called the second verse I
didn't know we had first verse I didn't
know Logan Paul sang I know very minimal
things about this video so I thought
it'd be really fun for me Marie and I
had to react to the video but to turn it
into more of a game because this is not
from this and at all whatsoever we
wanted to make it a game for ourselves
so I thought we would come up with five
different things each of us that we
think might happen at some point during
this music video and if they do we get
points and by the end of the video Weber
has guessed the most amount of things
wins question okay I'm going to test how
much you are to know about this okay
just love the pulp sing or rap I don't
they look like a white boy hood rat so
here in all I know about this video just
so on the same page it doesn't look like
I'm cheating because this is obviously a
game that I need to win to make my life
feel full so hopefully his brother Jake
Pau and him have had public beef lately
what I know also not only how old Ryan
has mowcher called that
private reporting for duty to private
beef I guess they're going back and
forth and like publicly kind of shaming
each other
Jake Paul posted a billboard of an
unflattering photo of Logan to promote
his merch exonic yeah
and so this is Logan's response and him
doing that the only other thing I know
in this that when I googled it I came up
with the headline is that Jake called
ex-girlfriend is in this video with
Logan Paul Wow yeah and she's like she'd
said some stuff about her relation with
Jake that he like cheated on her all the
times that she posted like an expose
video kind of thing
the she shows up at some point in this
and that's basically all I know so now
we have the right five things that we
think might happen and based on that
she'll knowledge of this video and Logan
himself and see see what we come up with
are we sharing them with each other and
the private we're going to oh my traffic
camera operator come five and we'll come
back and share what each other has
written and then we'll watch the video
hi
okay so we're back so we've written down
our five things that we think might
happen during this music video let's
start sharing them okay everyone -
someone with an accent
rap oh that's a good one yes someone
with a non-american accent oh I say
Logan wings directly to camera
oh I said Logan is shirtless oh I say
slow-mo running chase sequence is
someone to come a car in slow motion Oh
a plaque for process a oh that's it
going I said closest of the girls but in
a bathing suit I hid hoverboard chase
ion we're two chances and I said as an
animal you'd regularly see at the zoo
features oh and my last one is Logan and
drag
okay well let's see yeah let's see what
happens and what's beautiful I mean the
good thing is we don't have any to say
one no not above okay so this is going
to be a real okay if you get it right
you mustn't put it on your head but I'm
sure find a sticky note on their head
okay here we go
is it me 22 yes ma'am I'm really nervous
yeah what's up y'all are my custom again
brown colors so I'm just going to feel
amazing really a great service where's
the new body ours but I think what is is
what put on is it on this is vlog this
is vlog what's the first off what the
hell is happening
wait that's what all song but this is
thermo couple days ago or in psycho this
is this is this is the one just your two
roasted 190 years Oh ignore the
beginning fill the follow Jake Paul here
we go
okay I mean one phone call I got the
same house if you say cars to really not
that hard
oh hey by the way welcome to the top
little brother show the good huh
but let's not forget how you got your
garbage that you call us oh hey you
wanted me but else you read all your
life and got my subscribers energy
detector this [ __ ]
I live in weekly on money to run through
funny dude your investors no T penny
makin any money she starts with all the
Pomodoro looking at your face yeah I got
nothing let's do it without the night
just about any show
my dad never expected traffic always the
stuff you don't know what you tell me
you're like okay I'm going on the bottom
you stop okay team notoriety Turkish
catch your friends watch with their baby
I thought you were my point yes I have a
baby cow my doctor doesn't clearly dance
also but please replace them with the ha
ha ha please I own eyes - I will delete
my pop in the mail I can't take it again
[Applause]
[Music]
they cut right before Wow join the
strongest family on the Internet
physically maybe they're very in shape
well this didn't go as planned
I got one and I got maybe someone sits
in the car in slow motion that I miss I
couldn't tell us a lot jitter yet they
were guests Law & Order fall back
Doge in the beginning could have been a
zoo animal no one knows what's here back
I mean he was in his own merch no it was
a drag this is no weight is there
impressive don't come for me don't come
from me Paul [ __ ] I cracked the
audible.com plug I drink I chose my
drink because I felt so comfortable
why don't mind Argus for their finances
that they're spending as much money but
also like they only give their friends
10% so maybe not that much okay so for
you know I was ELISA got bumped in out I
wish I was cars you know she was exactly
like a process being tightly Jenner and
Kim Zolciak oldest daughter yes so
that's pretty symbolic okay I'm so sorry
this didn't work no it's okay I think
this is an educational experience unless
there's no guarantees in the ideas that
you have there's also no guarantees in
your career so please respect your
finances and terms of the vehicle maybe
we're going to go work on our
Rapp of Hannah Hart oh you the new
YouTube general quickly we need to use
we need possible affairs
we need views that's our rock that's
just roasted ourselves yeah you regatta
roses
we're already overcome yeah we've been
in that oven way too long don't worry or
burn I hope you guys enjoyed this video
if you did give it a thumbs up because I
make videos inconsistently maybe that's
why if you make himself consistent
brains you don't rush we're going to do
the opposite of a roast we're going to
build each other up like trying to
defend you from yourself
I've already made me channel and check
out us answering some of your burning
questions cuz it got real over there
it did get real not as real as that I
mean like their Thanksgiving it's good
it going to be rough okay
I'm exhausted Museo I don't know I bet
grandma's face goes in the mashed
potatoes that's a net and calling it
yeah then they start selling mashed
potatoes as grandma Logan grandma Paul's
message a no-bake Kristen goes out of it
like Miss Baelfire
[Applause]